bonjour bonjour
maïté je vois des produits en tous cas
l'un d'entre eux est extraordinairement
étrange sait pas trop ce que c'est a
beaucoup de choses mais des choses
curieuses
quelle imagination mais aujourd'hui on
va à commander des choses pas chères et
des restes bon mais qu'est-ce que vous
avez l'intention de faire comme recette
on va faire un coeur de boeuf farsi que
voilà et puis le reste de lapin quand on
marche des cuisses et l'érable
bon ils restent tous à la tête et il
reste le corps le lait les pâtes de à
varetz alors que souvent vous avez fait
des recettes avec les cuisses et
scharner c'est difficile on déverse il
ya beaucoup de choses mais au fond il ya
encore branché et c'est très bon ça et
on ne jette et c'est vrai simple à faire
en plus et encore ducharne eu des bonnes
choses sur les petites et les battre
c'est le meilleur parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'eau sont sus ça c'est
excellent puis vous savez que j'ai connu
une personne âgée il ya bien longtemps
quand on servait du lapin voulait
toujours la tête
mettez pas la plus bête elle dirait
tiger autres fonds se disputait la vesle
à la tête d'une affaire faut pas oublier
c'est la loose à toutes les têtes même
alors pour toutes les recettes qu'est ce
qu'il vous faut comme produit bon il
nous faut du vin rouge
oui une faute du père il nous faut du
persil il nous faudrait ciboulette
il nous faut désolé nous faut de
l'oignon il nous faut du citron de lay
lady lay aussi il nous faut des dents de
muscade anneaux à moi mais je trouve
beau un bel os à moelle
parce que leila mois si vous êtes déjà
on appris il nous faut des avants de la
peine voilà les têtes des têtes de la
vente reste est un superbe coeur de
boeuf
alors mettez le coeur de boeuf on
pourrait dire la même chose qu'aux
militaires pour le lapin tout le monde
veut du filet tout le monde le du rhum
ce texte et tourne dos des choses chères
et assez vite pipe et les abats c'est
excellent et pas chère à ce curieux de
voir comment vous allez l'accommoder
c'est très facile de parler car bien
entendu je prépare la farce en premier
voilà très bien que vous mettez dedans
alors
on se sent souvent de pair à deux ont
quand même l'habitude et vous mettez sur
nos amis seulement l'ami de faire alors
là il faut prendre du peyrat c'est parce
que c'est beaucoup plus facile et quand
même parce que si j'avais dû père assis
je le ferais centre les maires et puis
voilà mais il y en avait pas alors on
avait que du bon en berne père ferait
alors je vais le tremper un petit peu
avec du lait voilà ce qui va pas gâcher
parce que ce sera moins sec ont bien sûr
voilà
mais qu'est ce que vous allez ajouter de
ré bien mettre tout ce qui assure à
table là on commence à revivre zeste de
citron tiens puisque c'est là un ils
entendent pas pour ça va ça va ça va je
crois après puisqu'on est à gratter et b
alors la noyade
les lots de muscade ça va très très bien
assez bon ensuite l'ag bélanger jus
mettre le beurre un petit peu de beurre
je vous engage à mollir à france 3
propose un mélange et si vous ne mettiez
un peu de couleurs pour ça j'avais
d'abord mélanger sa mort chaque chose en
plus et c'est un peu de noms je trouve
que c'est un peu tout blanc
moi j'aimerais bien quelque chose qui
relève doit vous laisser faire ça va y
être alors là il ya la ciboulette à
berlin c'est ce que j'espérais tout très
bonne petite guerre ben c'est déjà à
l'après le wisla et ensuite vient la
moine et la moelle et vincent avaient
d'abord parce que j'allais faire pour la
sortir on récoltera ces bruits vous
l'avez chauffer un peu gelé chauffer un
petit peu comment vous l'avez vu dans
une casserole avec des casseroles avec
de l'eau bien entendu alors là même sur
la démolition qu'une importance et
puisqu'il faut lâcher
elle va venir tout seul ou la cité par
la mena là on va leur retirer un petit
peu qu'est ce que c'est bon ça la moelle
de bon sens excellent
bella s'assure un petit croûtons grillé
avec du sila bien sûr que c'est meilleur
que le caviar alors pas pousser quand
même hein si c'est bon alors très bien
je retourne le tout et on va rajouter
les jaunes d'oeuf qui vont nous lier
tout ça tout ça là alors un alors les
journaux de la faudra bien deux oui
parce que ça et penser aux scellés au
poivre voilà bientôt on va la mettre
moi je sais rien je ne vais pas que
j'oublie jamais bien ce que si j'oublie
je vous savez très bien mais mes yeux
elle seule fois que je ne le sait le
poids je le mets pas ce que vous aimez
bien les choses que nous vous voilà
alors prendre une bière et à la couleur
regardez ça si c'est bien ça va être
très parfumé pour avoir bien ri parce
que c'est plat sell in et on va farcir
et vous allez faire sur plateau payer
aux par les troupes à nous à l'arrière
mais d'abord je vais le paraît un petit
peu
nettoyez parce qu'il ya tout ce gras et
ça c'est très dur à faire ça et ça c'est
pas beau mais alors on en a les seins en
ever aussi revendre comme ça vous encore
un peu là aussi net que possible quoi
oui là à les voir ensuite et avant de
mettre comme ça pour le farcir par les
trous ou là par les alvéoles comme
montre
voilà je vais vous laisser on va remplir
ses origines année
la patron vous m'avez dit pas ce que ça
va gonfler un peu la face à caen alors
que la chair du coeur va se rétracter
d'où le trou est grand quand même et
elle est là regardez moi ça c'est gros
faux pas mal de stars
ensuite je la mayotte avec cette belle
trippin la toile de fond de toile ça va
pas d'officier ilan ou non parce que
tous à savoir que s'ouvrait pas tous
savent à caguer on dit partout et puis
c'est ça ça veut bien dire ce que ça
veut dire
de par ses merveilleux pour ça parce que
ça fait une robe regarder ça et en
fruits et en suite et ensuite j'ai mis
de la grèce dans ma cocotte qui est bien
chaude ou et à mettre le bébé on peut
mettre bébé à cuire et là je vais y
mettre aux voix roger corman d'hubert un
bon vin rouge un peu par à cuire dans le
vert
aussi longtemps et n'ont pas trop fort
une heure une heure et demie pour le
sourire il faut pas que ça beau fort
fort fort fort fort il faudra retourner
sauva et puis voilà on va le surveiller
alors ça nous laisse du temps maintenant
pour voir ce qu'on peut faire avec des
restes de la faire je les coupe en
morceaux
c'est pas trop nous en bd tête de côté
oui non et quel avenir et vous avez mis
de la grèce de la concorde
maïté il ya quelque chose à côté ils
sont cédés au nude revenir ça c'est 2
oignons
bien sûr le landais retourne un peu la
zone euro
enfin de la mère s'est très vite puis la
faire oui alors s'armer l'oignon de crue
en risque à voir les rennais le la
faites vous des faits ça n'est que comme
ça c'est bien mieux parce que j'adorais
un peu vous savez le sont pas mal
d'autres partis notamment bout d'un
moment c'est bon alors vu c'est la
victoire d'ali
je vais vous faire les pilardeau dans la
ventrèche que c'est un appel dans
d'autres régions de france du lard de
poitrine
on peut faire ça mais quand on a la
chance d'avoir ça donne un petit goût
bien sûr et c'est bon et nous on a la
chance de l'avoir
alors on va remettre vous laisser la
couenne
ah oui là on met tout ça là dedans
regardez-moi ça se savait pas petit sens
caché et ça fait des vents restent
regarder et à écouter ça aurait été bien
dommage est allé se perdre ce bourg ne
remet évidemment
alors maintenant je vais y mettre
l'oignon comme une couverture pour là
dessus il faut recueillir de cuir
regardez-moi ça et l'oignon ça va faire
un autre petit clip de judas enrobé tour
l'était faut dire que la france et ce
n'est pas comme si on peut dire comme
une humidité sur la sphère sont vus on
va le couvrir de fer et cuir tout
doucement
combien de temps il faut à peu près de
lueurs une petite demi-heure le meilleur
peut-être avons-nous le temps de faire
encore une utilisation de reste
évidemment dit comme l'aimé bien sûr
mike et vous avez désosser les petites
pattes du lapin les pattes de devant et
une partie du corps et qu'est ce que
vous en faites
alors maintenant le retour de la
manivelle on va le lâcher voilà et les
petits lardons pareil on va mélanger
tout le lapeyre et les l'ardeur de ça
c'est un peu plus dur de l'avant ça va
ça va aller c'est bon 12 ans est l'âge
et fait fuir des pommes de terre aura
prévient tout va bien avant jérémy de la
graisse de canard probablement dans une
poêle à chaud bon ça y est je crois vous
pouvez le prendre là non pas parfait
parfait c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon ça
va réveiller alors je vais faire revenir
tout ça
probablement la panade ça va cuire on va
casser les oeufs on va tout faire un
matin on ira à toutes les deux à
l'endiguer marne
voilà
c'est merveilleux shire on va aller
porter probablement saler poivrer
vous allez retourner vos tournées un
petit peu de la faire votre avis qui
attendait ça va tout seul et blanc le
lapin et la rdo sont cuits ensemble mais
qui bien mais parfait alors on va
peut-être
qu'est ce que vous faites maintenant on
va mélanger les pommes de terre dans
deux dans l'axé nourrissent arrêt ça va
nourrir selon le ser je vais y rajouter
la persillade qui va devoir les la
solide à un oui avec une salade ne veut
pas dépenser d'utilisation drs alors les
voulez vous battre encore où c'est fini
c'est fini selon ce qu'une session bien
voilà on met l'omelette et vol
voyez que les vertus de la paire son
passé et sa mine une impatience et on va
présenter les plats le choeur sac si il
est beau il est beau parce qu'il est
rose et les perceptions a besoin oui bon
vous le laissez cuire un petit peu plus
mais normalement c'est comme ça qu'on
est meilleurs comme ça ça veut dire
comme ça il est plus tendre pierre la
bip mois alors un plat très facile à
faire et puis cet appétissant cet
appétissant et sans goût extraordinaire
c'est très bon qu'est ce que c'est
simple et pas cher en plus mais bien sûr
pearl oil un vélo molette avec une l'art
d'utiliser les restes dollar parce que
c'est pas compliqué en ti boucan canot
rien du tout
trois pommes de terre 3 url et reste un
petit peu de vent très chaud si on n'a
pas à rentrer chez eux tant pis mais
sûrement c'est mieux on va voir là bas
il ne faut jamais rien jeter et si vous
avez des restes ayez un peu
d'imagination et ça passe et ça serait
dommage de vous en priver voilà bon
appétit
bon appétit à bientôt au revoir
[Musique]